now to present the nominees for the
outstanding actress award we give you
versatility talent and dedication all
rolled into two Richard Dreyfuss and
Shirley MacLaine
could I just take a moment and where is
he
until everyone hear how proud I am of my
little brother
I talented sweet adorable intelligent
mobilising sexy brother
Warren Warren one just imagine what you
could accomplish if you tried celibacy
not me Jack the the nominations for
outstanding performance by an actress in
a leading role are Ingrid Bergman in
autumn Sonata Ellen Burstyn in same time
next year
Jill Clayburgh in an unmarried woman
Jane Fonda in coming home
Geraldine page in interiors
the winner is Jane Fonda
I'm so happy I wanted to win very much
because I'm so proud of coming home and
I want many people to see the movie I'm
signing part of what I'm saying tonight
because while we were making the movie
we all became more aware of the problems
of the handicapped over 14 million
people are deaf they are the invisible
handicapped and can't share this evening
so this is my way of acknowledging them
I'm so proud and grateful it's been
almost eight years this this film coming
home was was born in Santa Monica where
we live in the cramped offices of the
Indochina peace campaign as a lot of us
whose lives have been bound up with the
war sat on the floor and some of them
were veterans and I think I thank all of
them one of them was my husband Tom
Hagen one of them was Bruce Gilbert who
has become my partner and is the
associate producer of coming home I want
to thank Waldo salt the first how do you
heavy the first industry heavy who stuck
his neck out and believed in the project
in fact he believed so much in it that
he worked for two years for nothing and
he led us to Jerry Hillman our producer
who fought for us and I want to thank
you Jerry
very much and I want to thank Haskell
Wexler who photographed it so
sensitively Bob Jones who came through
in the pinch and I want to thank Hal
Ashby you're not here hell but I want to
thank you for your taste and for your
courage for your ability with the
scissors and I want to thank penny
Milford and Bobby Carradine and Bruce
Dern and my pal Jon Voight and Mike
Medavoy and Eric Glasgow and Arthur Krim
and Martian acid ER for getting us the
money to make it and finally I want to
thank my children Troy and Vanessa for
being understanding and forgiving me my
absences and again my husband who helped
me believe that besides being
entertaining movies can inspire and
teach and even be healing thank you all
of you thank the Academy